we're receiving conflicting reports this
morning about whether Isis has been
defeated in the last territory it
controls in Syria at its peak in 2015
Isis held an area in Syria and Iraq
almost the size of Indiana but four
years later the militants have lost
nearly all of that territory the final
battleground is in Baku's that's eastern
Syria for two months
Charlie Daggett has been reporting on
the u.s. back fighters tied to trying to
take the booze back he sent us this
report
the US backed Syrian soldiers here tell
us there's still some fighting to be
done and that last Isis camp needs to be
fully searched before they'll declare an
outright victory but from what we've
seen it's certainly close we've never
seen battle-hardened frontline soldiers
this laid back one look at their faces
was enough to know the final fight
against Isis had just about come to an
end after weeks of airstrikes heavy
bombardment and close quarters fighting
it's finally come down to this that's
all that's left of Isis and it's
tempting to describe the scene here as
almost peaceful without the backup of
the 2000 American troops on the ground
and tens of thousands of US and
coalition bombs from the air victory
would have been impossible but the bulk
of the fighting came down to the Syrian
democratic forces what does it mean to
you it's a mix of great happiness and
sadness SDF officer Thiago Ahmed told us
many of our comrades have been killed
what they lacked in equipment like using
mud for camouflage they more than made
up for with courage now the defeat of
Isis on the ground is a major milestone
but tens of thousands of Isis members
and supporters have melted away and they
will continue to pose a threat to the
security of this region for CBS this
morning Charlie d'Agata in eastern Syria